[Applause]
in texas the holy trinity is god
football
and barbecue
not necessarily in that order
i don't care if you win just cover the
damn spread mom are you betting again no
fourth down got a punt
gotta statistically always punting on
fourth down makes no sense statistically
you're a dumbass hey when the aggies
give up the ball on their own five yard
line the opposing team has a 92 chance
of scoring when they punt from deep in
their own territory the other team still
has a 77 percent chance of scoring but
since they convert on fourth down 50 of
the time the math says they should never
punt again
okay you can tell me who's this real
daddy
sheldon i've been playing and coaching
football all my life
i don't think your math is right
really
hang
on no it's right
is it your dentist the little guy with
the glasses
you can tell me
[Applause]
hang on hang on what
let's go for it
why
we got plenty of time i know still want
to go for it
we're on the 12 yard line everybody know
you punk why does everybody know when
something make it right
well we're on the 12-yard line coach
okay
coach says we're going for it
stupid brother what
nothing
power left jumbo one two one two ready
statistically they're better off going
for it says who my little boy
that's why everybody punts that was just
plain
little
foolishness
a real genius well actually he is
come on
too many men on the field
defense replay
thank you jesus now can i send in the
punt team
coach
[Applause]
[Music]
remind me to tell you about the tax
refund they got from the irs
[Applause]
[Applause]
i never had any doubts though
[Applause]
[Music]
calling